ha pasado Ya más de un año y medio desde
que empezó la invasión a gran escala de
Rusia contra Ucrania y esto es una
noticia mucho peor de lo que podríais
imaginar Por qué Pues porque la teoría
política dice que es un conflicto se
alarga más de un año lo normal es que
termine durando más de una década Por
supuesto que esto es solamente una
tendencia histórica y que hay un montón
de excepciones pero si os fijáis veréis
que hay un montón de casos de conflictos
que se han prolongado durante décadas
enteras y lo cierto es que ahora mismo
casi todos los analistas apuntan a que
los ucranianos van a tener guerra para
rato por ejemplo Esta es la opinión del
ex general británico Richard barrons que
ya hemos mencionado alguna vez aquí en
visualpolitik atentos Ucrania no puede
ganar a Rusia ahora pero la victoria en
2025 es posible y por supuesto la peor
parte de que esta guerra se estire más y
más se la llevan los ucranianos pensad
que aunque no salga todos los días en
los medios de comunicación
internacionales el ejército ruso está
bombardeando ciudades y pueblos
ucranianos prácticamente a diario pero
este conflicto también supone un
quebradero de cabeza para los socios de
Ucrania socios que están haciendo
enormes esfuerzos para ayudarles y en
especial podemos destacar a uno El Tío
Sam
la administración biden se ha mostrado
como el gobierno más comprometido tanto
en el campo militar como en el terreno
económico a la hora de apoyar Ucrania
pero claro la guerra ya va para
prácticamente dos años y en algunos
círculos políticos de Washington ya
están surgiendo claras señales de fatiga
algunos incluso temen que la Guerra de
Ucrania se termine convirtiendo en otro
conflicto eterno una especie de nuevo
Afganistán que termine costando miles y
miles de millones de dólares para
escasos resultados o que desvíe la
atención de asuntos en su opinión mucho
más importantes por ejemplo contener al
creciente peso del dragón chino en el
mundo recordad que hace no tanto que
Estados Unidos escapó de otro conflicto
interminable con unos resultados
desastrosos el Afganistán deja ya
Estados Unidos una factura de 2,26
billones de dólares y luego tenemos a
los republicanos muchos como el propio
Donald Trump Están en contra de seguir
ayudando Ucrania y no olvidemos que
tenemos elecciones en Estados Unidos en
el año 2024 pero de lo que piensan los
republicanos sobre esta guerra
hablaremos en otro vídeo que
publicaremos muy pronto aquí en visual
política Así que si no os lo queréis
perder ya sabéis suscribíos al Canal si
aún no lo habéis hecho y dadle a la
campanita en cualquier caso si Estados
Unidos cortara el Grifo sería la peor
noticia posible para gif prácticamente
supondría el final de la guerra y la
derrota de Ucrania por ahora en
Washington siguen a tope y tanto los
dólares como las armas Siguen fluyendo
sin descanso para alimentar la
resistencia contra Rusia sea como sea
esto ha hecho que aquí en visualpolitik
nos hagamos unas cuantas preguntas clave
primero Cuánta ayuda ha recibido
realmente Ucrania por parte de sus
aliados segundo qué han hecho los
ucranianos con la asistencia que se les
ha dado tercero Hasta qué punto puede
estar decayendo el apoyo a Ucrania estos
días hoy en visualpolitik vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
El Tío Sam al rescate
en este año y medio de guerra entre
Rusia y Ucrania un asunto ha copado el
día a día de la política exterior de los
aliados de gif Por supuesto que me estoy
refiriendo al grado de apoyo militar y
financiero prácticamente esta cuestión
se ha convertido en el principal Pilar
de la política exterior occidental por
ejemplo Durante este tiempo las
instituciones europeas han comprometido
casi 85.000 millones de euros muchos de
ellos en forma de préstamos pero con
mucha diferencia el país que más
recursos ha movilizado en ayuda militar
económica y humanitaria han sido los
Estados Unidos de América que han puesto
sobre la mesa ayudas por valor de unos
70.000 millones de dólares le sigue a
Alemania un país que se ha puesto las
pilas en los últimos meses con otros
21.000 millones de dólares ahora bien
que sean los países que más dinero y
recursos han dado no significa que sean
los que más esfuerzo han hecho porque en
términos de pib Estados Unidos Apenas ha
invertido en esta guerra el 0,3% de su
economía pero para que os hagáis una
idea países más pequeños como lituania
Estonia o Noruega se acercan ya a casi
el 2%, O sea casi el 2% en apenas un año
y medio es una cifra formidable para
países que no tienen tropas desplegadas
en el terreno concretamente estos que
veis en pantalla son los países que más
esfuerzo han hecho Para apoyar a Ucrania
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando todos
pero por qué tanta ayuda porque los
países occidentales se han volcado a tal
nivel con Ucrania
Pues pensadlo bien si los aliados de
Ucrania no hubiesen ayudado a defender
este país tarde o temprano Rusia se
hubiera impuesto en la contienda y lo
más probable es que a estas alturas en
Kid tuviéramos un gobierno títere de
Moscú eso podríamos darlo por supuesto y
hubiera sentado un terrible precedente
para otras dictaduras con ansias
expansionistas por ejemplo china china
hubiera tenido prácticamente vía libre
vamos a ser claros y para occidente esta
guerra es extremadamente barata la otan
ha logrado debilitar a uno de sus
principales antagonistas que Rusia sin
pegar ni un solo tiro ni perder a ningún
soldado además se acerca a su órbita de
influencia a un país enorme como es
Ucrania
es decir que desde un punto de vista
puramente pragmático es totalmente
lógico mantener el apoyo a Ucrania pase
lo que pase puede parecer que la factura
es inmensa pero si tenemos en cuenta
todo lo que occidente gasta en seguridad
y defensa al final es una auténtica
ganga por ejemplo lo que Estados Unidos
ha puesto sobre la mesa es menos de una
duodécima parte de lo que se gasta cada
año en sus fuerzas armadas y esto es lo
que el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden lo tiene muy pero que muy
claros
American
[Música]
Estados Unidos está poniendo toda la
carne en el asador Pero en qué se ha
traducido todo esto Cómo se llama
materializado el apoyo militar que
Ucrania tanto necesitaba en el campo de
batalla Pues en envíos masivos de armas
munición y nuevos sistemas tanto de
ataque como de defensa
ya desde 2020 Estados Unidos comenzó a
realizar de armamento Ucrania que por
supuesto se intensificaron desde el
comienzo de la invasión rusa a este país
más de 35.000 lanzagranadas armas
pequeñas toneladas de munición y
sistemas antitanque han copado los
envíos recurrentes de Estados Unidos a
las tropas ucranianas Pero además de eso
El Tío Sam también ha entregado varios
sistemas de lanzamisiles tierra aire
como el famoso jaimas con un alcance de
80 km 10 más que el m30 smarts usado por
el ejército ruso también ha enviado
cientos de equipos de artillería drones
como Los Fénix Ghost y vehículos
tripulados como los 20 helicópteros m y
17 más de 100 sistemas de radar 31
tanques abrams más de 200 vehículos
blindados Bradley strikers 1700 sistemas
antiaéreo stinger y el sistema de
defensa antiaéreo patrio la lista total
es larga muy larga prácticamente tan
solo Estados Unidos le ha dado Ucrania
un ejército completo incluso ha
gestionado directamente la entrega de 45
tanques de 72b de la era soviética y
Estados Unidos ha reparado con la ayuda
de la República Checa
y por si todo esto fuera poco en la
reunión del g7 del pasado mayo que tuvo
lugar en Japón vaiden anunció que
Estados Unidos apoyaría también a sus
socios en el entrenamiento de pilotos
ucranianos en aviones de combate
especialmente el famoso f-16 al que le
dedicamos aquí un vídeo desde luego que
la ayuda que Ucrania ha recibido hasta
ahora es poca cosa y precisamente por
eso Muchos esperaban una acción
Relámpago una acción una contraofensiva
que sin embargo no se ha producido Por
qué pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
buscando más cartas
seguro que muchos de vosotros habréis
oído decir alguna vez que este conflicto
ha revolucionado la forma en la que se
hacen las guerras Al fin y al cabo esta
es la mayor guerra que hemos visto en
muchas décadas y la tecnología está muy
presente en este caso los drones los
vehículos no tripulados e incluso el
sistema de internet de los más que
starling están jugando un papel clave y
por supuesto que os voy a contar de
todas las super armas que Rusia Lleva
años vendiéndonos sin embargo Lo cierto
es que a la hora de la verdad esta
guerra es bastante viejuna se está
apareciendo mucho de hecho a las dos
guerras mundiales del siglo XX hasta se
ha recuperado la importancia de las
trincheras que ya vimos en la Primera
Guerra Mundial que tuvo lugar hace más
de 100 años y luego por supuesto tenemos
a la artillería que también jugó un
papel clave en la Segunda Guerra Mundial
y que en esta ocasión está siendo
prácticamente el equipo militar más
importante eso explica por ejemplo la
enorme cantidad de bajas o la enorme
destrucción de pueblos ciudades e
infraestructuras que estamos viendo
estos días es a todo esto Ucrania ha
recibido toneladas de armas modernas
armas pensadas para llevar a cabo la
contraofensiva de este año 2023 una
campaña que finalmente comenzó en el mes
de junio y que se espera se mantenga en
marcha hasta finales de este mismo año
hemos publicado hace muy poco aquí en
visualpolitik un vídeo donde os hemos
contado ya todos los detalles y por
ahora Lo cierto es que los avances han
sido muy limitados en parte porque el
gobierno ucraniano no ha querido
arriesgar más de la cuenta
Y es que veréis a pesar de que el
pentágono los había pedido atacar un
punto del frente con todas sus fuerzas
en gif tuvieron miedo de que esto le
supusiera perder muchos equipos de los
que les habían enviado y que de no
triunfar la ofensiva luego ya no fueran
capaces de repetir esta acción era
jugárselo todo a una carta y los
ucranianos prefirieron no hacerlo
Estados Unidos chocan sobre la
estrategia de la contraofensiva las
fuerzas pueden atravesar las defensas
rusas pero el tiempo se agota según
funcionarios de Washington pensad que se
enfrentaban una formidable defensa
construido durante meses y meses que
prácticamente sigue este esquema que
veis en pantalla una zona minada fosas
antitanques seguida de dientes de dragón
trincheras y artillería dicho de otra
manera que las tropas ucranianas no
tienen otro remedio que ir avanzando
lentamente tratando de abrirse camino
entre zonas minadas mientras a la vez
son atacados por la artillería rusa los
helicópteros y los drones el nivel de
bajas es muy elevado y la posibilidad de
avanzar rápido es prácticamente nula sea
como sea las duras defensas rusas
explican Por qué en lugar de jugársela
todo a una carta los ucranianos optaron
por atacar de forma más selectiva y más
limitada diferentes puntos en el frente
ruso hasta encontrar una factura Y eso
es justo lo que encontraron en Robotín
aquí es donde lograron abrir la brecha
que luego fue consolidada con la entrada
en combate de la poderosísima octogésimo
segunda brigada de Ucrania que es la que
cuenta por ejemplo con los challengers 2
británicos el problema de no seguir la
hoja de ruta marcada por el pentágono es
que Ucrania ha renunciado a intentar
desbordar masivamente al ejército Ruso y
sabéis Qué significa todo esto Pues un
consumo mucho más intenso de munición sí
habéis entendido bien Ucrania está
protegiendo los sistemas de armas más
importantes que le han entregado pero al
mismo tiempo está prolongando la guerra
de artillería y tiras y aflojas
constantes y esto supone mucho más
tiempo y sobre todo muchos más recursos
por supuesto estos recursos tendrán que
seguir saliendo de donde han estado
saliendo durante todo este tiempo de sus
aliados occidentales y aquí es donde
encontramos un posible problema una
guerra más prolongada y la necesidad de
dotar constantemente al ejército
ucraniano de nuevos equipos que pueda
terminar erosionando el apoyo a la
propia guerra Así que ahora la pregunta
es hasta qué punto puede el cansancio
reducir el apoyo occidental a Ucrania
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
peligro por agotamiento
Seguro seguro que a muchos de vosotros
la Guerra de Ucrania os ha desesperado
en algún momento hablamos de un
conflicto largo un conflicto que por
momentos parece estancado y al que no se
le ve una salida muy clara que este
sentimiento se generaliza en países como
España Italia o Francia puede ser no muy
importante pero cuando eso ocurre en tu
principal Valedor que es Estados Unidos
la cosa cambia de repente te enfrentas
una amenaza existencial y sabéis que eso
es lo que parece estar pasando en
Estados Unidos en este momento la
mayoría de los norteamericanos apoyan a
Ucrania pero el cansancio político que
poco a poco va surgiendo Es evidente más
de la mitad de los estadounidenses ya
piensan que su país ha hecho más que
suficiente en este conflicto y no porque
perciban que ya no es una amenaza para
la seguridad Nacional de los propios
Estados Unidos o la estabilidad en el
mundo la mayoría lo Sigue pensando el
problema
El problema es que veréis la realidad es
que 8 de cada diez estadounidenses están
especialmente preocupados de que el
conflicto se termine convirtiendo en una
guerra eterna es decir que Ucrania
termina siendo un nuevo Afganistán y
esto es lo que explica otro dato más que
es el que le preocupa a celensky en
torno a la mitad de los estadounidenses
y por momentos más del 50% no quieren
que el congreso siga probando paquetes
de ayuda para Ucrania esto probablemente
se debe a que solo uno de cada cuatro
ciudadanos estadounidenses creen que
Ucrania está teniendo éxito de verdad Y
para colmo algunos políticos y medios de
comunicación también están aprovechando
noticias como esta para criticar la
intervención en la vieja Europa casi 90
millones de adultos estadounidenses
tienen dificultades para llegar a fin de
mes según el censo pero no sólo eso
después del devastador incendio que han
sufrido en la isla de maui en Hawai el
Gobierno Federal anunció cheques de 700
dólares a cada hogar afectado lo que
suscitó durísimas críticas basadas en
que el gobierno se estaba estando más en
ayudar a Ucrania que saben dónde está en
el mapa que a los propios ciudadanos
americanos y claro todo esto ocurre
justo cuando vaivén necesita que el
congreso apruebe un nuevo paquete de
ayuda Ucrania de más de 24.000 millones
de dólares sin la asistencia militar
externa probablemente la resistencia
ucraniana colapsaría en el plazo de unas
pocas semanas
lo más probable es que los paquetes de
YouTube Ucrania se sigan aprobando en el
congreso Por qué Pues porque es mucho lo
que está en juego pero a pesar de que
esto sea lo más probable también nos
encontramos con noticias como estas
estos son los 70 republicanos de la
cámara de representantes que votaron a
favor de cortar toda la ayuda militar
estadounidense a Ucrania el
representante presentó una enmienda al
proyecto de ley anual de defensa para
cortar toda la ayuda militar a Ucrania
habéis oído bien el sector más trampista
del partido republicano no quiere
mantener esta guerra y claro os recuerdo
que en 2024 es decir el año que viene
hay elecciones Y hoy por hoy Trump
encabeza las primarias republicanas Es
más si finalmente fuera candidato y
volviera presidente uc tendría un
problema grave por supuesto en Moscú
conocen perfectamente esta situación y
por eso intentan alargar todo lo que
puedan la guerra aunque se les cueste
miles de bajas visto lo visto no sería
extraño que pronto viéramos una nueva
gira de zelenski por los Estados Unidos
pero sea como sea y llegados a este
punto turno para vosotros si arriesgaba
y den a continuar dando dinero Ucrania
sabiendo que es una política
crecientemente impopular a un año de las
elecciones presidenciales podría
resultar esto en el fin de la
presidencia de Joe biden y la vuelta de
Donald Trump Y cómo creéis que manejaría
Trump este conflicto podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios y
como siempre no olvidéis Que aquí en
visualpolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos
Todas las semanas así que suscribíos a
este canal y darle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un saludo y hasta pronto
[Música]